a standing ovation in paris for the
final performance by dancers of the kiev
city ballet alongside france's opera de
paris the ukrainian company started this
tour of france a day before russia's
invasion
for the troops 30 or so members the
opportunity to dance throughout the
devastation has been a lifeline
we are exhausted
we're both physically and emotionally
exhausted everyone in ballet is worried
about their
families about loved ones friends
colleagues at home
it's
it's been very difficult
being able to focus on work is
kind of a bright point in our day
when we get focused on the ballet steps
and focus on music and something other
than the conflict in ukraine
taking the stage at the theater de
chalet the dancers performed a medley of
ballet classics including excerpts from
swan lake and the nutcracker by russia's
prize composer tchaikovsky
but they were few in number
the most of our artists are stuck in
ukraine they expect to come to join us
after the first performance
but they couldn't unfortunately
the dancers have been given
accommodation by authorities in paris
and fellow artists
ticket sales from this performance go
into various ngos including the red
cross in support of ukrainian civilians
and despite the war raging back home
these dancers are determined their show
will go on
chilean wolf al jazeera